[Musique]
la plages d'agnès est un huis clos en
plein air ma petite chronique ismaël
maillot en fluo aujourd'hui c'est
l'incontournable auteure compositrice et
interprète à mailhac ammoura qui prend
un peu le soleil avant choquée qu'elle
donnera ce soir sur la croisette
bonjour aia bonjour mr faut c'est ce que
j'avais envie de voir vos ongles je vois
qu'on a fait un petit raccord avec avec
le pied toujours à faux ah oui ouais ça
va avec tout ouais vous êtes déjà venu à
cannes mais c'est la première fois au
festival du lac mcfauld festival de
cannes ouais bah oui alors quelle
impression immédiat je suis impressionné
par ce que je vous dise quand je pensais
pas mélanger travail et plaisir en même
temps en fait tenu des bons tu vas voir
les gens sont là enfin ils font ce
qu'ils ont à faire et puis basta
maintenant je pense que les gens sont
vraiment en train de chine est équipé de
se retrouver en fête et du beau monde
sas a vu sa manche c'est cool le
festival de cannes c'est plutôt un
endroit où ambiance suzhou avec sa bande
de copines et que sa bonne de koutio na
waie arrachement tu viens pour thil et
aimable et deux ans tu peut mélanger les
deux venir avec ponts des eaux et des
venir avec tes copines en même temps
mais ça fait bon ménage ça va alors vous
avez fait rêver quand vous partez quand
je me suis arrivé hier soir et je repars
demain matin malheureusement d'accord
vous savez bien rester un jeu des bleus
bah ouais c'est qu'il ya du câprier qui
vient la semaine prochaine mais je suis
en concert et alors qu'est ce qui se
passe avec dicaprio un secret non mais
j'aime bien et je suis pas vraiment de
de lui on pas de pare de tous calibres
de dicaprio vous adorez titanic il ya le
loup de wall street
la caisse qui a mis en a plein il ya
trop de films de lui mais tout s'est fié
lointier quand je regarde un film de lui
et enfin quand je regarde une affiche et
à lui à l'affiché du musée immédiatement
que le film il va être super est ce que
le cinéma ça mon temps oui et non parce
que c'est compliqué qu'est ce qui est
compliqué je sais pas si
chiffre est bonne en actrice je sais pas
trop bien joué la comédie à comment vous
savez ça ne savait pas bien joué parce
que c'est compliqué faut dire faudra
prendre le tout scénario c'est relou
faut prendre le scénario faux après faut
jouer pour rejouer annoncé ses résultats
en termes on est remonté une scène ça
n'a rien à voir avec un clip à voir faut
de la patience j'ai vu vous aviez fait
des études de stylisme et que vous avez
décidé d'arrêter pour vous consacrer à
la chanson
baho de vue au début j'ai arrêté pour
trouver un travail chose que j'ai jamais
trouvé ça m'a fait tatouer travail
emprunt il enrage avait pas de mon cv
n'était pas très intéressant
il y avait quoi dans le sais mais je
sais pas j'avais laissé ma copine une
bonne copine l'aï rendu de l'étude deux
commères de plein de trucs mais enfin
elle a travaillé dans la vente et moi ça
ne m'intéressait pas du tout du tout du
coup je commençais à l'eau studio et
ouais
restons dans le sens quelle est votre
musique des films préfet je dirais
céline dion voix c'est celle qui m'a le
plus de titane et un ouais ouais je
pense que c'est celle qui m'a tirée dans
la tête
ah ouais ouais j'aime bien bodyguard
chic et pas mal de très très bien est ce
qu'on mange une glace
ouais sur la plage dan graham worthy
direct direct
bonjour de chocolat de la grèce on
termine en bonne bonne copine à ok
[Musique]